Let's dig in a little more to see how the number of features that you use in
your algorithm is connected to the bias-variance dilemma.
Remember what we said before is that a high bias algorithm is one
that pays little attention to the training data and is kind of oversimplified.
It just does the same thing over and
over again regardless of what the data might be trying to tell it to do.
On the other hand an algorithm that's too high variance,
pays too much attention to the data.
It doesn't generalize well to new situations that it hasn't quite seen before.
It's basically just memorizing the training examples.
And as soon as it gets a new example or a new data point that's not
exactly like one of the training examples, it doesn't really know what to do.
Another way to think about this is that it's overfitting to the data.
Another thing that would be fair to say is that high biased algorithms tend to
have high error on the training set.
So in the case of a regression, for example, would be mean a low
r-squared value or a large sum of the squared residual errors.
High variance on the other hand might have a very, very good fit to the training
data but a bad fit to the test data because it's not generalizing very well.
So as soon as you give it something new it starts to run into
problems right away.
You usually expect to do a little bit better on the training set than you do
on the test set.
But high variance means that your doing much better on the training set.
But high variance is when your over fitting to the training set,
you get much worse performance on the test set.
So, here's a quiz question for you.
Let's suppose you have an algorithm that's only using a few features in it.
Out of, say, very many that you have available to you.
So maybe one or two out of dozens, potentially.
Without knowing anything more about the exact problem or
the exact features that you're using, do you think that this would
be more inclined to be a high bias situation, or a high variance situation?
Click which one sounds right to you.